me with my index fund according to the
data not according to anecdote according
to data hard data I'm not performing 99
percent of day traders what is pop is
sneaking today I want to tell you guys
about why you will almost certainly fail
at day trading now I made a video
yesterday where I kind of memed on some
day traders made fun of them literally
2:15 in the afternoon right now haven't
even eaten nothing all day man
trader lifestyle was really difficult
but it surprised me how many of you came
back to me and said oh no no no gurus
such and such as legit no no my gurus
legit and I think there's a fundamental
disconnect here because as I understand
it day trading is a game that you will
almost certainly lose and it's clear to
me that a lot of you guys don't believe
that and maybe that's because of all the
marketing that's been going on with
these gurus so I want to set the record
straight just for a second set aside
your favourite Forex trader you know
your favorite day trader because they're
trying to sell you something let's be
honest they're trying to sell you
something they have incentive not to
tell you the honest truth about day
trading and maybe even they will tell
you oh yeah you know a lot of people
lose but here's what you won't they'll
give some reason for why you're special
or why they're special and how they're
gonna suddenly make you successful even
though the majority of people fail most
people kind of know that but let's go
over the actual numbers because I think
getting familiar with the actual
statistics helps people make better
informed decisions I did this with
Amazon FBA when Amazon FBA was all huge
I did a video showing that only 8% of
third-party Amazon sellers make even a
fry Cook's income guys like not a lot of
money just a fry Cook's income only 8%
of third party Amazon sellers will ever
hit those numbers so in this video I
want to do something similar and just
show you how difficult day trading is
and I know a lot of day trading is about
that excitement the hustle the day
trader life but I think if you get a
good grasp of the numbers if you
understand the numbers you won't be so
convinced so I'm hoping those of you who
are kind of mathematically savvy will
really pay attention to this video and
understand the studies the statistics
behind all this because you guys can't
escape the reality of the two
so before we get into these studies
we're gonna go over two important
scientific papers about day trading I
first want to say to those of you who
are gonna say oh yeah of course the
majority of day traders fail the
majority of youtubers failed the
majority of anything fails wrong proved
over and over again we ang the problem
with that is that investing is one of
those rare kind of domains where you can
get all the advantages of investing with
basically no effort using something
called an index fund which is what I use
and it's a passive investment tool where
you just put money in you set it you
forget it and over time index funds have
consistently outperformed almost every
other super flashy investment tool so
you can with basically no knowledge or
effort get the vast majority out of the
stock market you know you might not be
making as much as warren buffett a year
but you don't have to do anything you're
not spending your life on finances
whereas as we will find the majority of
day traders who are spending their life
looking at a screen trying to you know
chart the data they're not even
outperforming an index fund so myself
and maybe you if you decide to invest in
index funds or whatever you decide to
invest in you can basically be doing
nothing and outperforming a majority a
vast majority of these day traders who
are flashed in the Lambo and whatever
you're making more with your index fund
so let's go over the numbers I want to
show you guys in the data let's jump in
so the first paper we're going to be
looking at is day trading for a living
where they do a brief summary of the
literature on day trading and they
explain the following study after study
has proven that the majority of day
traders don't even make a profit they
lose money day trading check this out
this paper found that only 36% of day
traders profit another study finds that
25% of all retail day traders profit
another study finds that only 19% of day
traders profit so most people are losing
money that's already a given right but
how many people are actually making more
money than you would with an index fund
because I'm going to assume for a second
that you guys don't want to waste your
time day trading if you're not making
more than an index fund holder like
me right so with that in mind let's turn
our attention from not just who can
profit at all but who can profit more
than an index fund right who can make
more money than you would if you just
set your money and kind of forgot it
well this is where we go to another
study called the cross-section of
speculators skill this study looked at
day traders in Taiwan from 1992 to 2006
and here's what they found less than 1%
of day traders are able to predictably
and reliably earn positive abnormal
returns net of fee so after you pay your
fees 1% actually less than that what
less than 1% is able to earn an
above-average return do you understand
how crazy that is so me with my index
fund just sitting here right no matter
what the Guru's say they could say that
they're special all they want me with my
index fund according to the data
not according to anecdote according to
data hard data I'm not performing 99
percent of day traders now part of that
is because of the fees but part of that
is for another reason because this is
looking at what's called retail traders
and retail traders are people like me
and you who are just handling our own
money we're not working for a bank now
we need to consider institutional
traders because when you're trading
right you're trading across the table
from somebody and more often than not
that person might be an institutional
investor in other words a bank and this
is where we go back to our next study
once again it's day trading for a living
and what's interesting about this study
is they say hey we think that actually
the fact that there are more hedge funds
than ever the fact that institutional
investing has gotten bigger than ever
the banks are bigger and bigger
percentage of the total shares traded
every day that fact puts retail traders
at a disadvantage because now is not
just Joe Blow on the internet versus Joe
Blow on the internet you know atom
versus atom
now it's atom versus gigantic hedge fund
supported by quants right it's atom
against Renaissance technologies one of
the few edge funds which consistently
has outperformed the stock market whoo
fun fact one-third of their employees
have a PhD in like math computer science
or
that's who you're trading against
sometimes and so what this study looks
at is look given that given that hedge
funds are bigger than ever
what's happening to the retail day
trader right the guy who is trading all
the time against these people are the
numbers for day traders actually getting
worse and yes they are because according
to this study which looked at the
Brazilian futures market this study
found that only 3% of day traders were
profitable after one year guys that is
insane
in other words 97% of them lost money
and this paper is really clear about who
they're trying to convince with the
findings they say this check this out
quote it is now very easy for anyone to
enroll in one of the many online courses
about day trading or to join live trade
rooms in YouTube where traders teach
retail investors how to trade in real
time we show that it is virtually
impossible for an individual to day
trade for a living contrary to what
brokerage specialists and course
providers often claim snake gang that is
it snake gang that's all you need to
know period
that totally nails it virtually
impossible for an individual to day
trade for a living contrary to what
brokerage specialists and course
providers often claim and one of my
favorite parts about this study is not
only do they call out course providers
in a scientific paper but also they say
okay look even if the people the 3% of
people who are consistently at least
going positive how much are they going
to positive right how much are they
profiting is it even possible for the
people who are profitable to be
profitable enough to be a millionaire or
to make all this money flashy lifestyle
Lambo whatever well this is where it
gets interesting and it reminds me a lot
of our Amazon study because check this
out in order to make a minimum wage day
trading you have to be in the top two
point seven percent of day traders let
me repeat that two point seven percent
of day traders top two point seven in
order to make a minimum wage this is
worse than Amazon FBA at least Amazon
FBA had eight percent of them making a
fried cliffs income so I mean like now
Bezos is looking great compared to date
but in order to make the profits of a
bank teller what a bank teller makes you
have to be in the top point six percent
of day traders now guys let's be honest
if you're looking up YouTube videos
about day trading you're not in the
point six percent of day traders let's
just be real
and let's also be real about the fact
that you can enhance your wealth by
having a real job and just investing in
an index fund so I hope this really
clears up a lot of the confusion about
day trading you know there's obviously a
lot of hype around this industry even
now scientific papers are calling out
core sellers for for their fraudulent
claims but guys at the end of the day
you guys have to look at the data not at
the hype you have to look at the math
not at the madness so I hope this has
helped you get a better picture of is
day trading right for you I would go out
on a limb and say that it's not right
for almost everyone most people are
better cut out for just passive
investing but whatever you guys think I
want to hear about it in the comments
section below I know not everyone's
going to agree with this video but I
want you guys to tell me why you agree
or disagree which part of it you agree
with do you think that there's some guru
that still has a magical power with
investing or do you think that these
economists are right that with the rise
of hedge funds it's now harder than ever
to beat the stock market consistently
and that honestly you're better off just
grabbing an index fund let me know in
the comments below and of course I will
see you guys next time as always don't
forget to smash like and subscribe thank
you
[Music]
Ferrari